[Applause]
so we were both we were thank you so as
you were at the tree lighting as well
that's the most recent place we were at
the same place right did you have did
you have a good time I had such a good
time it was so much fun I think I I
think it was like my eighth year doing
it and by the way I you were awesome by
you look beautiful in that white coat
thank you it wasn't mine my stylist is
actually Michaela my stylist and she was
I was supposed to wear dresses and last
minute I was like oh hell no no I was
thinking about because it was so I felt
like cryotherapy out there it was so
cool how said I was like oh how's she
singing and oh I was very terrified yeah
yeah and then I was just like Lord if
you love me at all just like I'll take a
few notes off key but if you could just
kind of keep me in line most of the time
it was really funny M was cool too I
cried though the tree I've never
experienced it physically in person like
being turned on and in and I didn't
realize it was going to happen it's so
beautiful it is beautiful the spruce
they call it with the spruce it looked
like we were in freaking hooville it did
right yes I always say it feels like
we're in inside a snow globe right there
it's like a Christmas movie it's awesome
and it kind of officially kicks off the
Christmas season so that was awesome I
know Savannah and hot were laughing at
me CU they were like are you crying and
I was like yes it's like it's so
beautiful anyway so do you have any
family H holiday traditions that y'all
do I mean you know we have the the
family come over and they everyone kind
of hangs out at Casa Lopez and my wife
being Italian and US of course being a
Mexican a lot of food good food hanging
out so we're eating a lot Dr again just
like Annie invite me over I'll come over
do it it's a big party so I love Italian
and Mexican
[Music]
[Applause]
food than here guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home